[Music]
it is a book that it's rocketed up
bestseller list this summer the chain by
Adrienne McEntee is a chilling thriller
that has spooked readers worldwide
especially parents but perhaps even more
riveting than the story of the chain is
the backstory of the author this part of
Massachusetts is dense with literary
meaning Adrienne McKinsey's the chain
begins on picturesque Plum Island
Massachusetts a small beach community
about an hour north of Boston it is an
area soaked in sunlight and slow
tradition not the sort of place most
people would pick for a dark thriller
but for McEntee it was perfect you feel
that that there's this kind of terrain
that this is like something uncanny in
this world at the center of the chain is
a young mother named Rachel whose
daughter is kidnapped and who in turn is
asked to kidnap someone else if she ever
wants to see her child again this is her
first steps into the moral abyss really
she considers herself a good person but
then she starts actually thinking about
doing this thing for real the
desperation McKinney's main character
feels is unnervingly familiar what was
the lowest point I think the lowest
point for me in the last five years was
about two and a bit years ago for one
reason or another we ended up being
evicted from our house and when you're
evicted the landlord comes in and he
puts all your stuff on the sidewalk of
your house and I remember all my kids
like furniture and all their little
clothes and stuff for all out in the
sidewalk of the house my little daughter
Sophie turned to me and said daddy is
everything gonna be okay and I looked at
her and I said of course everything's
gonna be okay everything's gonna be fine
but meanwhile in my heart and my head
I'm thinking well is everything gonna be
okay I don't know what is that like when
your daughter asks you things are gonna
be okay after you just got evicted from
your home
it's makes you feel horrible as a father
as a dad the number one responsibilities
of a dad is to make sure that his kids
are safe and happy and when what you've
been doing in your life has led to these
set of circumstances you just feel like
a complete and utter failure but you
were a successful writer I mean you had
you had written a lot yeah I was a
successful midlist writer McEntee has
written over a dozen novels none have
been hits like the chain I've been
coming here since 1993 so 26 years and
now you're a best-seller here it almost
never happened after he was evicted I
decided okay that's gonna end I'm gonna
stop writing I'm gonna stop being a
fraud
I'm gonna stop going on this male ego
trip that I was enjoying and I'm gonna
get a job I went the very next day to a
job center and I got work in a bar that
afternoon I started bar work I started
doing bicycle delivery guy and I
enrolled in uber which my wife thought
was hilarious and because I'm a terrible
driver at the bottom of Plum Island
bartending and uber driving may have
helped pay some bills but they were not
his bliss as he was reminded by fellow
author Don Winslow's Winslow connected
McEntee to his Hollywood agent and
screenwriter shane salerno salerno
convinced McEntee he had a big hit
inside a story set in america the idea
behind the chain is something that Ken
t's been thinking about for years it's a
combination of those hokey chain letters
you might remember from childhood and
kidnappings that have taken place in
Mexico where someone's allowed to
substitute themselves for a loved one
who's been kidnapped we won't tell you
much more so we don't ruin any big
surprises but the books pacing is
relentless as Don Winslow's says it's
jaws for parents at the center of this
book is a very powerful female character
that is Rachel mm-hmm and someone who's
not really an expert at that no at
kidnappings or anything else but it's
forced to become one yeah here's a
mother who literally goes down into hell
to get her daughter back from the
darkness that's apocalyptic yeah it is
apocalyptic the book starts here yeah
more or less at this corner here one
McEntee set in the chain in a region
that has been home to literary elite TS
Eliot
Robert Frost and John Updike he tosses
their names around with reverence and
here you are showing up in a in your
Ulysses my you'll see much to my wife's
horror she said to me you can wear this
in the plane but for God's sake don't
wear this in the interview and you're
wearing it in the interview so I'm huge
trouble if this ever airs I'm in huge
it's airing right now oh my god
Mackenzie's newly energized life is a
joy to watch a timeless lesson if
somebody's out there watching this and
they're maybe they're ready to give up
on something not feeling inspired what
do you say yeah well my story is
completely the story of the writer who
had quit and it's the oldest story in
the world
never never never quit because you just
don't know I tell everybody this do not
quit ever ever I am writing I am writing
I'm doing it
I have been I have been threatening to
do it I'm doing it don't quit I just
want to read the book yeah it you can
move through it in a weekend or a day
because it moves that quickly and now
it's been optioned into a movie by
Paramount yeah you'll see it on the big
screen likely soon and Mackenzie that is
Irish right and but then spent a lot of
his a lot of time on Plum Island when he
visited relatives including his stepmom
over the years and so that's why there
was that connection to this place and it
is there is this eerie it's a beautiful
place right but there is a little bit of
it you meanness to two times like it's
sunrise sunset where you can see right
what to Napster's right which yeah
that's right